what's up the leaves nation I started to
mention me series to try to learn from
people who have done a lot more than us
spend a little bit more time with them
and hopefully some of their beliefs
their viewpoints their mindsets keeps in
Dodge to help us become the best version
of ourselves so today we're going to
learn from Arnold Schwarzenegger and
some of his most inspiring moments
mentor me Arnold and as always guides as
you're watching the videos if you see
something that really resonates with you
please leave it in comments below and
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired and if you write it down
it's much more likely to stick with
yourself as well
[Music]
you
the most important thing is that you
have a vision did you have a code
because without that vision and without
that core again you're drifting around
if you're never going to end up anywhere
people don't become successful just by
accident you know I mean maybe the guy
that found gold in California and
started the gold rush but don't count on
that that's the one in a lifetime kind
of a situation so you got to really have
a specific order to me to have that
vision that I want to be mr. universe
they don't want to be the greatest
bodybuilder of all time that was a great
vision and that specifically to look
like reg Park and to be up down that
stage and to lift the trophy overhead
and to win the championship over and
over and over again so that was a great
core you have to have a corner it
doesn't have to be that specific code
but it has to have some core this is why
I always recommend to people sit down
take your time instead of thinking about
why do you want the workout what is your
call and then you can't be as crazy as
it is it could be you know I want to
impress girls if that's your call so be
it but it motivates you it could be that
you're emulating a certain you know body
builder or a certain football player
certain boxer whatever it is half those
pictures put all over the wall like I
did when I was a kid I put pictures of
fridge pocket of Sonny Liston of boxes
and of Ali and the power lifters and
weightlessness all over my bedroom in
the wall so that every day when I go to
sleep every day when I wake up and look
at those pictures and they motivate me
you need that motivation and then
therefore you have this kind of imprint
in front of you all the time and you
know exactly what you're chasing this is
why I always smiled when it was in the
gym people always came up to missus why
are you smiling you're working out five
hours a day you're doing the same as the
other guys but the other guys have a
sour face they're pissed off that they
have to do another rep or another set or
something I look forward to I look
forward to another thousands of students
I look forward to another 500,000 of
Lake bridge o squad I looked forward to
in more and more curls until my arms
fall off why because I knew that every
Reptar that did and every set that it
and more weight to the lifted I get one
step closer to turning that vision into
reality so I was turned on by that I was
excited I couldn't wait to get to the
gym when I used to do seminars on how to
become a champion I would always ask
people why do you want to be a champion
or what do you want to accomplish why
are your training and they will if a guy
will get up and you would say well I
want to train because I think that if I
get muscular and you know I feel like
I'm getting the kind of definition then
maybe can enter a bodybuilding
competition does it sit down as if you
think this way you're going to be a
loser
you're never going to make it because
there's no maybe you got to get up and
say I want to be a champion and I do
whatever it takes
amount of hours it takes to pose into
this so that's the visualization looking
at training footage looking at
motivational books with reading busy
whatever it takes I would do that's the
hands that I want to hear from you you
can detect right away those that are
going to be shaky and as we fall behind
and they will not go all the way and
goes to the very hungry and dead hungry
you have to develop because just to
create a goal for yourself whatever that
may be a short-term goal and a long-term
goal and you got to go after that and if
you do not feel and if you do not
believe it who else will don't be afraid
to fail anything I've ever attempted I
was always willing to fail in the movie
business I remember the depicts script
many times you think this is a winning
script but then of course you find out
later on when you do the movie that it
didn't work and the movie goes in the
toilet now we have seen my movies from
in red Sonia Hercules in New York class
action heroes those movies prints in the
toilet but that's okay because they're
the same time there is I made movies
like Terminator and
Moonen and True Lies and predator and
twins that went through the roof so you
can't always win but don't be afraid of
making decisions you can't be paralyzed
by fear or failure or you will never
push yourself you keep pushing because
you believe in yourself and in your
vision and you know that it's the right
thing to do and success will come so
don't be afraid to fail in one word one
word only now did a small-town boy from
Austria they come one of the most famous
people on earth why do only is aid in
one word one word I'll stay with you
rules dream dream dream I was poor
because it didn't have anything I had no
money I had no things yet the TV Viet
noticed Richard with nothing as kids but
it was rich because I had the dream and
enduring had a dream of becoming a the
greatest bodybuilder and had a dream to
use bodybuilding as a means to get into
films but I had no idea that he would go
as far as it did that it will go beyond
the body rolls beyond the muscle here
and then do movies like Terminator
predator end of days and stuff like that
that was like you know I had to kind of
reinvent my dream after I achieve that
ok but this dream I mean a body buddy
who comes out but there must be a time
in your life before that when you II
didn't have any source of bodybuilding
at all what so child way well I grew up
in Austria after I was born after the
Second World 1 1947 it was poverty there
was no food around no really nothing and
I think that was the reason why I
developed such an era men desire a
desire to get out of there and a desire
to make it in life to achieve big things
and then when another school later on
about America and about the disguised
scrapers the big freeways the big cars
know that I said I'm a surgeon I want to
be part of this big thing everyone has a
problem with time but the day is 24
hours and be sleep sticks now I know
there's some out there the trade of
evolve over 90 date what I say to sleep
a little faster
because the bottom line is we have six
hours of sleep 24 hours are available so
if 18 hours now available to your work
your family your hobbies and also to
learn something new or to do something
new which could easily be that you want
to learn a new language or that you want
to read and as a New Year's resolution I
have to read a book every week or where
you say I'm going to go and reshape my
body so you're going to go and take this
hour out of your schedule and say I'm
going to train an hour every day so this
is for most people a huge challenge but
it is totally tool well can tell them
because the kind of things that I did
when I came to this country I mean I
went to school I was working on
construction I was working out my five
hours a day I was taking acting classes
from 8 o'clock at night to 12 midnight I
was doing all those things I wanted to
make sure that out of the 24 hours of
the day that I don't waste one single
hour because hours were too precious and
so there's just want to tell people
don't keep me this thing I have a
difficult time of it the time and I
don't have time so there's none of that
you have time you make the time when
your competitive athlete you learn very
quickly a strong you are sharing you are
all those things but it could very well
be there's a lot of people forever
equally as good about it you have it
performs just as well there is us
muscular to take bodybuilding is exactly
the same kind of you know proportions
and all the things the question related
what puts you over the top this is the
mind it really creates the body is the
mind that makes you really work out to
four or five hours a day it is the mind
that visualizes of what the body ought
to look like is the finished product the
body is very important but the mind is
more important than the party we have to
visualize what that body ought to look
like in order to make it win because
that's what creates in the will the will
that you need to go to the gym every day
the will that makes you go into the
fourth strip the will that makes
go beyond he Dooley 500-pound reps in a
squad and you can't do another rep and
your body is shaking it's the will that
makes you go one more time down and
struggle up one more time and says all
this is a mental aspect that motivates
you and it makes the difference between
you being in the gym full of joy and
looking forward to doing that extra rest
and looking forward to doing this extra
hundred reps in the sit ups in working
past the pain Terry's that all is the
mind it's not the body so this is why I
think the body is very important but the
mind is more important than the body if
so many roles in life about everything
as they break the rules not the law but
break the rules but wife is a t-shirt
the wife is a t-shirt that says
well-behaved women rarely make history
or you know I don't want to burst a
bubble but the same is true with man it
is impossible to be a maverick or true
regional if you're too well behaved and
doesn't want to break the rules you have
to think outside the box that's what I
believe after all what is the point of
being on this earth if all you want to
do is be liked by everyone and avoid
trouble the only way that ever got any
place was the breaking some of the rules
after all I remember that after was
finished with my bodybuilding career I
wanted to get into acting you don't want
to be a star in films you can imagine
what the agent said when I went to meet
all those agents everyone has the same
line that it can't be done the rules are
different here just look at your body
here this huge monster his body is
overly developed this doesn't fit into
the movies you don't understand
this was 20 years ago the Hercules
movies now there is the little guys
today in Dustin Hoffman Woody Allen
Chuck Nicholson before he came wait of
course that is but anyway those are the
guys that Wayne and the Asian also
complained about Max and he says no one
ever became a star with an accent like
that especially with the German accent
in yes I can imagine with your name
Arnold Schwarzenegger or whatever the
name is on a billboard yeah that's going
to draw a lot of tickets until Allah
because you're right so this is the kind
of negative attitude they have but I
didn't listen to this rules even though
they were very nice in this if look we
can get you some good parts we can make
a get you to be a you know being a
wrestler or a bouncer oh maybe the
German actions you can get you to be a
nasty officer in Hogan's Heroes or
something like that but you know I
didn't listen to all that this was their
rules not my rules I was convinced I
could do it that if it worked as hard as
it isn't bodybuilding five hours a day
instead of getting the work I started
taking acting classes took English
classes took speech classes dialogue
classes accident removal classes are
even took I remember running around a
fine wine rose and a vine is it because
Sherman's are difficulties with the F
into W and the V to find wine grows in
the vine I know what some of you now
says it hopes that Arnold got his money
back but let me tell you something I had
a good time doing those things and it
really helped me finally I broke through
I broke through and a supplicating the
first part in TV streets of San
Francisco Lucille Ball hired me and made
pumping arms stay hungry and then it was
a big break in Conan the Barbarian and
there the director said if people
wouldn't have Schwarzenegger we would
have to build one now think about that
and then when a determinate er I'll be
back became most is one of the most
famous lines in a movie history all
because of my crazy action now think
about it the things that the agent says
will be totally a detriment and will be
impossible for me to get a job all of a
sudden became an asset for me all of the
things my actions my body and everything
so it just shows you never lose the dirt
it can't do something and you have to
work your way up of course run for
something else first I mean it was the
same when I ran for governor the same
lines that if the burger graphic can be
done and then of course I ran for
governor and the rest of course is
history they said you have to start with
a small job as mayor and then there's
assembly
and then they are lieutenant-governor
and then as governor and if that's the
way it works in a political career I
said I'm not interested in the political
career I want to be a public servant I
want to fix California's problems and
bring people together and bring the
parties together so like I said I
decided to run I didn't pay attention to
the rules and I made it and the rest is
history
thank you guys too much for watching I'd
love to know what did you think of this
video what did you learn from Arnold
that's going to have the biggest
immediate impact on your life or your
business which one was your favorite
clip and why please leave it in the
comments below and I'm going to join in
the discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout to vincent montello
Vincent's thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book here one word and
making that book summary video on your
YouTube channel I really really really
appreciate the support today we are
covering Evan Carmichael's your one word
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon